now
um 2018 august of 2018 i go for a
hypnosis session
who who uh hypnotized you this time um
yvonne smith in california okay and she
like with bud gone and leo sprinkles now
very old
so there's these key players in the
field that are getting kind of old and
have
either passed on or no longer doing the
work and
so she's sort of the main person now in
north america who's doing this
this type of research hypnosis so i went
to her office and
we had met a few times before at
conferences and she was we talked
and she actually had my book she has the
blue book the owl book
and so she um
so i went to her office and i had done a
session earlier and the same
story emerged again and i didn't believe
it i didn't know what to make of it the
first time the story emerged
what happened was i i did a session with
with um
a woman named mary rodwell almost a year
earlier and
i just didn't know what to make of this
story i just didn't know what to make of
it
so i said i'm gonna i want to explore
the night this is the night here of
march 10th
2013 i want to explore this night
so she takes me back the hypnotic
induction i'm very relaxed i'm lying on
her couch
the lights are low and in her you know
her little office looks like a therapist
office she's sitting in chair right next
to me we got our voice recorder in the
room
i'm laying stretched out on her thing
she goes through about a half hour
induction
like simple stuff like walking down a
staircase yeah
and she says where are you like
let's go to the night of march 10th 2013
the night you saw the
round structure on the hill it's like
and i'm like i'm lying there i'm going
well it's stars are out it's clear you
know i'm kind of like
doo doo doo like like am i under you
know it's like
i'm on the pillow it's pretty i can look
up and see this thing
i kind of have a clear memory of it and
she asks a few more questions and all of
a sudden i go
and this is gut wrenching to listen to
at times
this session and i just go i know it's
them
i know it's them i know it's them
and that was describing the light behind
the bush
and and then i'm
then i say i'm looking down at this big
thing
i'm looking down at this big round
structure it's got lights around the
edges but i'm above it looking down at
it
and and and i think i'm still in this my
body's still in the sleeping bag
and she goes are you out of body i'm
like i don't know i think my body's in
the sleeping bag
and i think i'm looking down at this big
round structure
and then there's this like
all of a sudden i'm on board the craft
can you can
scroll down a little bit i think i got
this here
keep going double click that one the
hallway
yeah so i'm so i'm all of a sudden i'm
in a hallway that looks like this
i did that as a piece of art okay and so
so i'm in this hallway and the very
first thing i see
i write the very first thing i recognize
now this is i had the same experience
before but it was all disjointed and i
was so freaked out
for some reason i'm much more calm in
this time and so
in this hallway the first thing i sense
is i'm not tall
i'm not tall i'm i'm
i'm short and i look to my right i look
to my left and there's a
gray alien on each side of me and
they're the same height
and i i looked on my hands i got these
long skinny fingers and i looked on my
arms
and i got this skinny space suit on and
i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] gray alien and it was like
totally normal and yvonne is just like
doesn't bat it
like what happens next and the next
thing that happens is i'm in this
conference room and it's like an ugly
conference room like you would see in an
ugly cheap hotel right it's got
beige carpeting and fluorescent lights
and folding tables and
and i'm standing there and then there's
this folding table it seems like it was
like between 8 or 12 there's a bunch of
beings they're all kind of fuzzed out
but they're
they're but i can only call it grey
aliens
now i'm going to just say this straight
up i
don't know what to make of this story
that i'm telling right now like
is it true is it not true did it really
happen like there's no
ugly conference room with ugly shag
carpeting on board a flying saucer like
so i don't know what i was seeing so but
i was presented with this vision in this
hypnotic session
i'm standing there in the body of a grey
alien looking at these beings
and i'm like what am i doing here why am
i here and i get this
voice in my head that says you
volunteered for this
like what is that supposed to mean i
volunteered for this
what what am i doing here now is the
time
so i'm like what does that mean now is
the time so it goes back and forth we
get kind of stuck in this little thing
and then all of a sudden i'm like
just overcome with emotion and i say
i said you never told me it would be
this hard being here you
never told me there would be sadness
there would be loneliness you
never told me that would be this hard
being here and they say you volunteered
for this
and i in the session i am like so angry
i am crying i am like this is [ __ ]
up like i'm here
i'm dealing with this pain i'm dealing
with these emotions
you have no idea how hard it is to be
here
you're like this is [ __ ] up
you volunteered for this and i get
super emotional and yvonne's like saying
what do they want from you
what do they want from me and i think i
see they want me to play
some role
and at that point like you can hear it
in the audio you can hear me gonna go
and i i remember lying on the couch it
felt like my heart stopped it felt like
my
stopped breathing my heart stopped to
feel like i sunk like i was so tense i
was crying i was screaming
like it was ugly like how angry i was
and
and i all of a sudden i'm i go from
totally rigid with anger and fear
like then like just totally relaxed
and this is long long silence
and yvonne says what happens next and i
said
i think i'm back in the sleeping bag
now before we started the session
with yvonne and i i said hey somewhere
in this thing when i'm like in this
vulnerable unconscious state
you ask me what's up with the owls
what's up with all the owls why owls she
said okay
so i'm like i'm back in the sleeping bag
she says mike what is your connection to
owls
and without skipping a beat now when you
do hypnosis oftentimes the answers are
like
really herky jerky and they're just a
little whisper and you kind of
mumble a lot and she said what's up
what's your connection with owls
and i speak very clearly i say
the owls aren't important the owls are a
sign on a door
the owl is the correct sign for the door
but the owl is not important it is the
door that it's important
i've i this was like seared into my mind
afterwards
so and i say
we are on this side of this door we are
trapped in this
tight little claustrophobic hallway
and on the other side of the door is an
infinite
vastness
and then she asked a few more questions
about some
and i was like i gotta get out of here
this is too much i gotta come out of
this
so she brought me out of the hypnosis
session so
i that was it was when i said i was
i saw this it was super emotional the
first time it was super emotional the
second time
it felt like i was watching a re-run
frame for frame rerun
of the exact same experience with mary
rodwell and then a year later with
yvonne smith
so i had two hypnosis sessions the exact
same story emerges
really word for word frame for frame it
was like watching
a re-run like you know when you like
click the scene i saw this one before
then you sit there for a half hour and
watch it anyway
i was like i wanted so but except for
the part at the end about the
the owls aren't important so this is
like for me i feel like i'm on a
therapist couch right now
like i'm i'm like i spent a decade
like owls owls owls and ufos it's owls
it's the owl thing i'm an owl guy it's
like it's i'm my identity it's my
work it's my passion it's this thing
that's
and then to have like me just blurt out
totally calm and confident the owls
aren't important
the owls are a sign and a door i took
that to mean the owl is a
symbol the door is that other realm
we are on this side in this realm
trapped in this claustrophobic hallway
that other realm is infinite and magical
and
enormous and we are stuck here
and that's there maybe when we die we'll
get there maybe
some you know i so anyway
i can tell you right now there is no
ugly
conference room on the board of flying
saucer and i can also say i
don't trust it right at the same time
it was powerful like powerful
so i'm in this place now where i'm
trying to like lead my life
from this place where like was i like a
grey alien in another lifetime and i
incarnated here on earth to perform some
role i mean that's
the message and and just so you know
that actually shows up a lot in the
research
when people go through hypnosis the
similar story
to that almost exactly the same thing it
shows up a lot and i knew it going into
it so i could have confabulated it i got
my
my the file cabinets in my head are full
of stories like this so i could if i
want to confabulate it i could i could
i couldn't do it i could create a doozy
of a story but
the first book the first all book the
blue book
i started writing that less than 48
hours
after spending the night in the desert
when i looked up at that
big round structure on the hill so i
didn't put this together until
like five years later right so i'm
laying on the
sand i see all this weird stuff i hear
uh
coyotes and my lights in by the bush and
i drive home and there's
you know i connect these things in a map
and then i start the book okay
five years later i get this thing where
i'm where like
the story that emerges which i don't
know if it's true or not is that i have
i'm uh i lived some
identity i incarnated as a grey alien i
lived some identity as
a grey alien i incarnated here on earth
to play some role
and i and i started the book less than
two days later
so you asked me why are they picking
these people
why are they choosing people what's
what's the meaning here
people like who've had these contact
experiences write books there's a lot of
books out there
i've read a lot of them so
what's you ask what i don't was it
given given your question the answer i
would
grudgingly give it's like why did they
do this to me it's like
i think it was to write a book about
owls because that's that's how it played
out
that's what happened and i didn't figure
this out until five years after the book
was published or
yeah so interesting